ZEINA OWEIS: Hi.
My name is Zeina, and
I'm a product manager
on the Google Play team.
As a developer for a
great Google Play app,
you're probably
thinking about how
to cover the cost
of your business.
And who doesn't
like to make money?
One way to monetize
your apps and games
is using one-time purchases.
But you may be able
to better monetize
your apps through
subscription-based payments.
Subscriptions are
great because they
allow you to form this ongoing
relationship with your buyers.
Subscriptions are a win-win.
Users sign up for these
auto-recurring payments
because they get the same great
value at a discounted price.
And in turn, you will get more
revenue and more happy buyers.
And subscriptions
currently work for apps
across a variety of categories,
news apps like "The New York
Times," sports apps like MLB
At Bat, and educational games
like those developed
by SmartEducation.
And subscriptions on Google
Play have been growing,
and they continue to grow
quarter over quarter.
Google Play Subscriptions is
included in our in-app billing
service, so you will get
the same great benefits
you're used to with
one-time time purchases,
including global
payments and automated
financial reporting
and deposits.
So your app never has
to directly process
any financial transactions.
On top of that,
in-app billing takes
care of the headaches
of recurring payments,
so you can focus on
building a great service
and a successful business model.
The developer console gives you
full control over the pricing
and the billing periods of
each subscription product.
Choose the billing period that
works best for your service.
We currently support monthly
and annual subscriptions,
and soon we'll support weekly
and seasonal recurrence
periods as well.
You can offer users multiple
options to choose from.
For example, you can
create a basic plan
that costs $5 a month and a pro
plan that costs $10 a month.
And free trials are a great way
to encourage users to try out
the service before committing
to the recurring payments.
Consult with your favorite
marketing professional.
They'll probably tell you that
free trials is the way to go.
When you add a
subscription product,
one of the options
that you can set
is how long that trial
period should last.
Of course, if you do choose
to offer a trial period,
the user who signs
up won't be charged
until after the trial
period has ended.
And like other
in-app items, you can
use Version 3 of the
in-app billing API
to validate the status
of a subscription
when users sign
into your service.
GetPurchases will return any
active subscription, including
ones in the trial
period and also ones
that have been canceled up until
the end of that billing period.
You can also fire up a purchase
intent by calling GetBuyIntent.
It's used almost the same way
as it's used for in-app items.
Just pass Item_Type_Subs
with the skew ID
of your subscription product.
The purchase token can
be used for synchronizing
the subscription state
between your back end
servers and Google Play.
So what about maintaining
those subscribers?
Sometimes, they may not
be completely satisfied
with the service that
you provide them.
If that ever happens,
you will soon
be able to offer them a free
week or two as a goodwill
gesture.
If you do that,
they will be happy
and may continue
the subscription.
Even better, when they know
that you are practically
compensating them for any
unforeseen bad service,
they will spread
the word, and you
will get more
people to subscribe.
Sadly, they will
sometimes still want
to cancel their subscription.
Again, you can do
that via the API.
You can cancel the
subscription at the end
of their current billing period.
And soon, you will also be
able to revoke it immediately
with a full refund.
What if you come up with a
new great subscription plan,
or you want your satisfied users
to move from, say, the monthly
to the annual plan?
Well, soon you'll be
able to easily trigger
a purchase intent for
the new subscription plan
and allow users to switch
from one tier to the other.
So what's next?
Well, if your app
can offer great value
to your users via
subscriptions, in-app billing
is as easy to use for
subscription-based payments
as it is for one-time payments.
And as I said, when
it comes to payments,
there's nothing for you to do.
We process all
recurring payments
and deposit them into your
designated bank account.
So you get to focus on
what you do best, which
is creating beautiful,
engaging apps and games.
If you're ready to
get started, check out
the documentation on the
Developer Help Center.
With the power of Google
Play subscriptions,
it's never been easier to create
meaningful and long-lasting
relationship with your users.
So go out and build
something great,
and thank you for watching.